good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all the major problems of the world and
today's message is make no excuses over
to you Jon Taffer the songs for 30 years
how is everything a restored about
success what do you do to be successful
management marketing cost everything in
my whole life was this what you do to be
successful this a we do this but now we
have the 92 bar rescues I know more
about failure than any persons on mmm
you don't even have to sell a drink to
make money last night vision
come here shaker give away his booze and
leave with your money don't walk to
failure there's a clock to failure you
can see it and I found because I've been
exposed to so much failure because
remembers a consult
most people either have money or some
level of success if they're calling the
people I go to a bar rescue can't afford
to buy me lunch I mean now broke so when
I take a look at the terrible situation
of the room and the pressure that amount
to determine or
the fact of the matter is the only
chance that I have of making a
successful is by making them accountable
so in all these rescues I've found a
common denominator of failure and it's
excuses so you wake up in the morning
you're familiar it's in the middle of
the recession eight years ago so you
blame it on a recession but even in the
middle of the recession somebody is
making money in Newtown right so that
excuses bull how about the excuse of
blaming the president playing Greece the
euro is affecting my income in New York
you can blame everything in the world
you can blame the weather the president
the mayor the city construction traffic
slow terrible Vista but the fact of the
matter is you're failing because of you
because in snow somebody made money the
cold somebody made money so every excuse
is bull you're failing because of you
so if you wake up in the morning and
look in the mirror and blame it on the
president you got no reason to change
but if you wake up in the morning and
look at a mirror and say I am a family
you're not going to like it and now you
have to change so I forced them to own
failure I will not allow them to push it
off on anything but themselves and when
you own your failure you won't like it
then you'll own your success successful
people don't make excuses successful
people don't complain if you look at
whoever you want to look up to look at
the most successful people in the world
in any industry look at the top and look
at how much they complain they don't
complain when you complain when you
blame something else when it's the
government's fault or interest rates
fall or the bad economy is fault
or your partner who screwed you over or
the customers who don't care as long as
you can blame somebody else right the
education system your parents your
friends your upbringing there's always
somebody else to blame and when you
blame somebody else when you're in that
mindset then you never grow you make it
things easy on yourself it allows you to
Coast it allows you to play live super
safe because it's not your fault that
you're not more successful of course
it's not your fault that would be
difficult that would be hard it's
somebody else's fault so you can just
stay where you are because people are
holding you back from accomplishing the
thing that you want to come to you we're
successful people take responsibility
for where they are in life and they say
I don't care for the government I don't
care who's president I don't care about
regulations that you have or things that
you're holding me back on I will still
go out and get mine and of course there
are other factors of course the country
you come from matters of course
education you have any and the
connections you had growing up of course
it matters but so what you have to play
the hand that you were dealt you have
these cards you have to play those cards
and you can have success one of the
things I love looking at and this is why
I do all these profiles is successful
famous entrepreneurs there is always
somebody who has done way more than you
have done with waste fewer resources
than you already have so no matter what
terrible situation you have an
empathetic maybe you have come from a
broken home maybe you have a really
severe disability that's physically
holding you back from doing some of the
things you
want to do you know maybe there's a lot
of pressure on you maybe you have some
disease maybe you have zero money in
your bank accounts these are real
pressures and an epithet ik to that but
so what
the longer you believe that those things
are going to hold you where you are then
they will there are people who have
worse conditions less money are in worse
situations and they came out of it and
accomplish amazing things because they
believed that they could and if somebody
looks like you has gone on accomplished
big things then you can too and it only
happens when you accept responsibility
for where you are in life so I could
look at my youtube channel and say the
YouTube algorithm changed the YouTube
algorithm is all over the place now I
can't figure it out stupid youtube for
changing their algorithm and hurt in my
videos I'm pumped whenever you 2,000
changes I'm so excited because the
people who are ahead of me the people
who are getting all the videos and all
the views the people who are complaining
I love it change it more because I'm
going to figure it out I love the
process of figuring that whenever
there's chaos I see opportunity and
that's what entrepreneurs do the most
important thing that you need as an
entrepreneur is not resources its
resourcefulness so that no matter what
is thrown at you and you're going to get
a lot thrown at you in your life you
have already had a lot of stuff thrown
at you and guess what as an entrepreneur
you're just going to get punched in the
face again it's going to get worse
you're going to get more thrown at you
it's going to be eating more crap for
years this is the life you sign up for
and on the other side is amazing so when
you accept responsibility for where you
are when you realize that in every
situation no matter how much outside
your control you think it is there's
always something that you can do to make
your situation better when you accept
that full responsibility and stop making
excuses that's when life starts to
change that's when your business starts
to explode that's when you start to see
the impact and financial wealth that you
want to create for yourself start to
happen
so the question day today I'm curious
what has typically been
the biggest excuse that you've had the
biggest complaint that you've had that
you pulled other people that as of today
is over leaving the comments below
different curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to Tina
Tina thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and making
that calligraphy art and your one word
is love I really appreciate that and I'm
glad you're enjoying the book so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope it seems to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
Press
[Music]
because the thing about you might ask
you the same let's relax on has dis out
and you may get a kiss you because you
talk
every since I was seven years old in
everything that I did and what I get up
early so hard and answers the render you
all understand if you go to life you
cheat yourself Derek Rogers all the time
at a certain season that roughly and if
you're not really supposed to be first
you'll always introduce you as though
you really are and if you learn American
art is left in the back like would you
have to be a [ __ ] German Morgan is
going to be a good wake up don't make
you stop serving say excuse if you if
you've got a sort of first thing you
said when you ever knew it happened and
you are making efforts and you say maybe
look like that you know better than that
Roma people his problem I'd like excuses
this is all about the Bundestag devices
and you look at him when information in
fact the hope an angel getting backup
moment you step back up you said that
one is not doing haha I was in
Johannesburg a little while ago and I
went through the the airport and I went
to the men's room or washroom or
bathroom however you want to call it and
so I walked into the men's room and the
first thing I hear is welcome to my
office and this was the janitor at the
Johannesburg men's room that's funny
hoo-hoo janitor eyes door I'll make up a
word that cleaned the men's the toilets
like Mozart composed music now that man
has no money that man probably has very
little education that man is judged by
the world as having an unimportant job
right and that man is a hero could be
here two millions of people why because
he actually saw himself as an ambassador
to South Africa and his passion was was
palpable and his visceral commitment to
doing work at the highest level was like
you don't see even from the CEO and all
I'm saying is even the person in the
with the broken heart the person who's
down on their knees whether they see it
or not they have a choice to rise above
their circumstances and leadership and
humanity is a testament to the people
who have done it I mean you read the
group you look at Mandela you know 27
years in increasing that when his son
died he wasn't allowed to attend the
funeral of his own son he said that was
the one of the great pains of his own of
his life and what did he do the victim
looks at something like that torture and
says I am broken and they give up and
they spend that they closed their heart
they closed their mind they closed their
creativity and they blame the rest of
their life on what happened to him but
Mandela what he chose to do was to use
it as an opportunity
because actually the things that break
your heart if you choose can open your
heart and adver fear the world says fear
is bad fear is only an opportunity for
bravery training and what he did was he
used those 27 years of torture to open
himself mentally physically emotionally
and spiritually to the point where when
he was released and became the president
of South Africa he invited his jailers
to sit in the front row at his
inauguration and he was asked why and he
said because if I don't I'm still gonna
I'd still be in prison and that's a long
way of saying but you know we do make
excuses because we are very good at
self-deception because if we actually
had to face the responsibility of
playing with our bigness in the world
we'd have to let go of our addiction to
our excuses and and leave what's safe am
I making sense now you're talking that
you have to leave what's safe I mean we
are addicted to crisis sometimes it
makes no sense we are addicted to pain
and we'd have to actually leave the pain
to gloat to the possibility of pleasure
and joy and greatness and believe it or
not that frightens us right so we make
these excuses and then we blame people
Oh Jo or Robin I don't like the way he
looks I speaks differently but
subconsciously as you're suggesting
those are just our protective mechanisms
to avoid owning the responsibility of
our brain what do you feel separate good
athletes from the best athletes I think
it comes back to what I was saying
earlier about I mean I think it's a lot
of it is mental you know if you want to
do something and you want it that bad
you'll make sacrifices and growing up
for me as a kid I made a lot of
sacrifices that I didn't seem that they
were a big deal and I don't seem there I
think I don't think of them being as
being a big deal right now you know
there were Saturday's or Fridays where
I'd give up going to a dance or hang out
with my friends I had to work out the
next day but those things that I gave up
you know we're things that I wanted to
to help me get to my goal
and and there were times where but you
know I've been put in uncomfortable
situations but I've used my mental power
my mental strength to push through it I
think that's how you you know you can
look at any of the athletes in the world
I mean Tiger the guy's a busted knee and
still comes and destroys the rest of the
field you know that's the thing like
people don't make excuses
they're some of the best at they're the
greatest athletes in the world do things
when they're uncomfortable you know
everybody can compete when they're
feeling good happy excited rested but
it's the best people who can overcome
when they're tired sure not in the great
mind not in the best mindset and I think
mental power that the greatest athletes
have can push all the pain aside you
know and I mean like when I was doing
that Navy SEALs thing it was easy for me
to do is no but the easy for me to climb
over a 45 foot wall and look down not at
all and I'm afraid of heights but you
know I said to myself I'm going to do
this and no one's going to stop me I
think that's the biggest thing
it's how strong you can be mentally I
think that really shows who the person
is so I think that's one thing that
separates the good from the greatest